hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar optimizing GI testing molecular
diagnostic testing for common stool
pathogens
I'm Christy Jolla blabbers and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by leverage and brought to you
by BB C D is a global medical technology
company that is advancing the world of
health by improving medical discovery
diagnostics and the delivery of care to
learn more about our sponsor please
visit molecular diagnostics BD comm /bb
- Mac - system forward slash
now before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is and
rises we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply you type
them into the ask a question box and
click send well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation click on the
support tab tab at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the ask a
question box located at the far left of
your screen this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speaker dr. Margie
Morgan professor of pathology and
Laboratory Medicine and scientific
director of the microbiology laboratory
sphere Sinai Medical Center dr. Morgan
has over 30 years of laboratory
experience first as a bench technologist
and then laboratory director her
professional focus has been
antimicrobial stewardship poster damn
difficile diagnostic strategies and
infection control measures an
application of molecular message to the
microbiology laboratory these interests
have led to over 100 abstracts and
publications
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen dr. Morgan you may
now begin your presentation
good morning everybody I'm Margie Morgan
I work in Los Angeles at the
cedars-sinai Medical Center in the
microbiology Department and I thank you
today for joining me for this webinar my
objective today is to share our
experience with you with switching from
manual to molecular methods to detect GI
pathogens so for the next 50 minutes or
so I'll tell you our laboratory story if
I do not answer all your questions
during the presentation there should be
time at the end for your questions so my
presentation is about optimizing GI
testing molecular diagnostic testing for
common stool pathogens so let's get
started
the primary diagnostic challenge of
course is about diarrhea and diarrhea is
really quite important it's a common
reason to visit a physician their
symptoms for many pathogens with varying
degree of seriousness and that can have
similar symptoms
so this disease can also be a particular
concern for children and immuno
immunosuppressed you're at risk because
their course at a greater risk for fluid
loss due to diarrhea but you know it's
always challenged me and laboratory uns
and physicians about what really is
diarrhea
well it's defined as greater than or
equal to three loose watery stools in a
24-hour time period test or during
patterns by physicians tend to be
somewhat random I know they certainly
are in my institution and I assume there
probably are in yours as well and
sometimes it's not based on patient's
history or current practice guidelines
just a patient shows up with diarrhea
and let's just take the attitude of
let's just look for everything and see
what you might have and then sometimes a
person may not be all that ill and in an
outpatient setting and we question that
is laboratory testing even necessary
so yes diarrhea is a diagnostic
challenge we have had some help over the
last year or so there are some new IDSA
guidelines that were published in 2017
and then
can provide us some very very useful
information in the laboratory and also
of course very good information for
clinicians to maybe they can better
understand the proper ordering of tests
for diarrhea some of the key points that
are in these guidelines is there's
clinical symptoms and patient exposure
history or risk factors that should
guide the help of acute gastroenteritis
diagnosis
they're also recommending molecular
tests for the most relevant bacterial
parasitic and viral enteric pathogens
they also really harp on that diagnostic
testing should be more selective and
limited to settings in which the tests
are more likely to provide clinically
useful results we need to think about
the history where is the patient been
and think about the individual tests or
groups of tests it should be ordered
perhaps we shouldn't head toward
ordering large syndromic panels are they
clinically relevant or all of these
diagnoses unnecessary
and we need to think about the impact on
healthcare costs in the massive ordering
of kind of shotgun approach to diagnosis
of diarrhea
further looking at the guidelines we can
see they look into exposure or the
condition associated with the pathogen
causing diarrhea and they kind of
separated into three groups they could
be helpful to clinicians and into
laboratories and developing algorithms
for the diagnosis of diarrhea and by
looking at this you can see is divided
into community acquired foodborne
travelers diarrhea the nose a Kamiel
issues such as C difficile and diarrhea
that is perhaps more chronic in nature
or has an unusual travel history or
unusual exposure to contaminated water
so we can use these guidelines to really
help us in trying to prepare diagnostic
algorithms and guidelines that can maybe
help clinicians more selectively order
laboratory tests so we are not so
bombarded with just massive pan orders
for many many passages
so all of these diagnostic tests are
supposed to be very helpful and they are
particularly helpful with the endangered
in the endangered I include the children
that are younger than five elderly
immune compromised patients that have
bloody diarrhea severe abdominal pain or
certainly those with signs of sepsis
it's also very helpful in the use and
selection of proper therapy that being
mostly antibiotics also it can help to
know if anti motility agents are
appropriate for use if hospitalized of
course we worry about contact
precautions also we could limit further
testing by doing in good laboratory
diagnostic testing by preventing further
workup and it could be a cost savings
for the hospital and also a cost savings
for the patient also we can assist with
Public Health outbreak investigations
I've worked in the laboratory for a very
long time and I've done many decades of
laboratory testing for stool cultures
and for OVA and parasites I've always
thought we've tried to do a very good
job we've tried to be very sensitive and
specific but I have to admit some days
may be better in my judgment on the
bench than others but generally I
thought we've done a good job with
sensitive and specific testing but I've
always thought that stool cultures and
we're labor-intensive it can take three
to five days to produce a final result
oh and peas I have to admit they were
not always my favorite thing to do and I
think I share that with the people that
I work with in my own laboratory you
have exposure to chemicals it's a lot of
labor involved and you have a lot of
interpretation that requires a good deal
of skill you can also have excessive
ordering patterns of stool pathogens
testing by physicians paired with less
than ideal test options and this can
lead to problems in the clinical
laboratory where you're just getting
lots of tests
and duplicate tests and repeat tests for
all different kinds of pathogens and
unfortunately laboratory uns can spend a
good deal of time working up negative
stools which can account upwards of 95%
of the stool samples submitted for
testing
this is just looking at what we all know
is the standard manual bench processing
for the bacterial cultures that we
received for stools
we have a variety of incubators that we
have to incubate into after we set up
the specimen we have plate reviews we
have to subculture mini colonies we
might have other tests to perform such
as E is and such as well and a lot of
times this is not a 24 to 48 hour
process this could go to three days or
longer for all the sub culturing the
workup of suspected pathogens this
possible susceptibility testing and
preparing organisms for the send out to
Public Health Department so this could
be up to 72 hours in time and of twenty
stools we're lucky if we have one
positive with all of this work if we
look at it in a more grander scale it's
really kind of alarming sometimes in how
many plates and different tests and
different types of equipment that you
have to have just to do a routine stool
culture to its upmost in your laboratory
so that's what this slide shows just all
the different kinds of plates incubators
different kinds of kits and readers that
you might find necessary in order to do
a stool culture so yes it is a bit
complicated
so one questions does this all make
sense well how about the cost of all
those things on that last slide there's
lots of auger plates broth tubes and
antigen test not just the cost but also
the training the competency records all
of the QC records for all of these tests
have to be maintained equipment we have
multiple incubators at different
temperatures
dia readers we have to produce the data
but is it possible that performing a
molecular multiplex assay might actually
reduce the total cost when compared to
the cost of all these labor intensive
methods that we do in a manual stool
culture now let's think about the labor
that I've outlined in those last two
slides there's many steps and there's
lots of CLS a CLS hands-on time in
performing those steps there's a lot of
screening out the normal flora to find a
pathogen and there's incredibly few
positive findings for the amount of work
and all of this media and equipment that
I have so the significance well there's
a great deal of work and time trying to
be very helpful but actually we're
delaying diagnosis sometimes we don't
have significant results until 72 hours
or longer down our pathway there's also
safety concerns if we're dealing with
pathogens out in our laboratory on the
bench we could have many bacterial
isolates being sent around the
laboratory for different testing methods
and this is a potential safety concern
so how about the value of molecular
testing in dealing with all of this well
molecular testing can give us a blend of
speed accuracy and also multiplexing
capabilities with the speed we can have
faster time to result than traditional
culture methods we can do a very highly
sensitive and specific way of testing
and we can examine a number of targets
concurrently without having multiple
plates and pieces of equipment but
there's come some key questions when we
think about switching to molecular
testing does molecular testing for fecal
pathogens really improve patient
management are there certain situations
or patient populations where a molecular
or multiplexed approach is particularly
well and how does this cost figure into
all of this analysis and so this is some
other things that we will be discussing
in future slides
first off this matech molecular testing
really improved patient management well
if you look at a therapeutic standpoint
rapid testing for stool pathogens using
mcgill molecular testing I think it
makes sense you can inform patient
management decisions and help minimize
the use of inappropriate or unnecessary
antimicrobials things like this can be
especially important when it comes to
the detection of like sugar
toxin-producing e.coli where if you had
continued antibiotic exposure you might
increase the risk of the patient
developing hemolytic uremic syndrome you
have more rapid diagnostic information
for the severely ill patient and I think
a very very important point in these
days with increasing healthcare costs is
if we can provide a very rapid molecular
identification of a pathogen it would
eliminate further downstream testing
such as colonoscope procedures when the
slow turnaround time of our conventional
diagnostic methods had not found a
pathogen so I do think molecular testing
does improve patient management
also molecular testing can assist in
public health from a public health
standpoint rapid testing for stool
pathogens using molecular testing makes
very good sense we have more rapid
alerts for outbreak investigations such
as finding Salmonella Shigella and sugar
producing e.coli smutch more rapidly and
we certainly help out our infection
control practitioners by finding these
organisms much faster which can lead to
proper infection control measures to be
taken more quickly in the hospital or
even in reporting these two people that
work in such places as long-term care or
in daycare facilities
but we come back to cost - let's look at
how does this cost figure into molecular
stool testing
these figures are a course from a
publication and all of us would need to
look at this closely in our own
laboratories and see how this cost
breakdown works for them so they
compared the cost of conventional
culture to the cost of using the BD Mac
system for doing molecular testing for
enteric bacterial pathogens and as you
can see in the breakdown in minutes the
conventional culture takes far longer
the supplies are also not minimal we
talked about all the plates and
different instruments that are required
and then the labor I think that's the
thing that's most outstanding with a
conventional culture is how many minutes
it takes to set up supply costs and then
total cost you can see when you put all
this together that molecular testing
really does not increase your cost that
greatly
there's many molecular assays for
passage and detection and it whenever
you're looking at moving in this
direction for your laboratory you need
to look at all of the options and see
which one would work best in your
laboratory multiplex molecular panels
are very well suited as a diagnostic
platform for stool pathogens they can
target select enteric pathogens and
provide very rapid valuable results
there's assay options available from
many different manufacturers and you
need to take a look at all of them and
see which one would best fit in your
laboratory situation they differ in
multiplex panel size they have bacterial
parasitic and viral targets and some of
them offer more flexibility and testing
than others most are sampled to result
automation with rapid turnaround times
of around 2 to 5 hours all of these
tests will improve your workflow
efficiencies in the clinical laboratory
and let's take a look at that in a
moment
the first question is why did we choose
to use the BD Mac system we did look at
all the methods available and we thought
that the BD max bit best in our
laboratory it targeted the most common
enteric pathogens it met our desire for
flexibility within a multiplex testing
format we were just able to selectively
test what was ordered by the physician
hopefully they're using our algorithm
which is based on symptoms and
epidemiology of the patient we very much
needed a separate C difficile testing
panel we thought that was very important
for our inpatient population we also
thought it was important to be able to
separate out enteric bacteria virus and
parasitic testing because in our
developmental algorithms we have it
selected out for certain patient
populations to only be tested for these
in certain situations
also the patient build list with a
selected target panel testing most of
our testing in our laboratory is on
outreach outpatient type testing and so
we thought being able to build separate
panels and selectively testing these
panels what's the best option for us the
BD Mac system is easy to perform
it has batch testing capability that met
our volume needs we do quite a few of
all of these per day and our laboratory
costs were within the expected range
I'm going to go through all of the
enteric pathogen panels and talk about
some of the pros and cons and different
things involved and I'm first going to
start with the BD max enteric bacterial
panel
this panel detects pathogens that cause
most of your enteric pathogens bacterial
disease over 95% so this may be the only
panel that you need to test it detects
salmonella Campylobacter Shigella and
Shigella toxin producing organisms let's
look at those stars that I have by
Shigella and sugar toxin I want you to
note that the Shigella species primarily
target Shigella but it can also detect
intro and bacey v coli the chicken toxin
producing organism says the primary
thing that it is detecting but it can
also pick up Shigella dysentery it is
very helpful that this has been FDA
cleared for both the testing of fresh
tools or for Kerry Blair transport the
BD max enteric bacterial panel certainly
improves laboratory workflow compared to
culture this is a very interesting
article that was written by dr.
mortinson and his group and it shows
that all the different steps of mapping
a culture it's really kind of amazing
when you think about all the steps on
all the movement around the laboratory
that you have associated with a culture
and when you compare a manual culture to
be d-max you would see that BD max has
an 82 percent reduction in decision
steps compared to culture and so you
have far less problems to deal with and
far less workflow issues to deal with so
it really makes for a very efficient
system to use the BD Max and Terry
bacterial panel
this is how simple the specimen prep and
operation is you first start off with
adding a specimen to the sample buffer
and as I said prior you can use a fresh
dual or a carry Blair stool specimen you
have to vortex the specimens once it's
added to the specimen sample tube and
then add to the rack
the strip's then need to be loaded into
the rack you have a reagent strip that
contains your PCR reagent snap-ins
that is in your sample rack that is
placed into the BT max then you place a
PCR cartridge in the reader and you're
good to go so it's really a about a
three to four step process that's a very
simple process to follow we perform all
of our sample specimen processing in a
biological safety cabinet and I think
even though this is a very simple
specimen prep and operation I cannot
overly stress the ability for all of the
molecular methods used in microbiology
of having a very strict sterility
protocol and making sure that you're
doing the tests at the best of your
possibilities so once you have
everything set up in the instrument
you're ready to go you can do back to
mode testing so you can do up to 24
individual tests per run and you can do
86 specimens in like a regular
eight-hour workday the hands-on time for
those 86 specimens would only be about
an hour and a half you do not have to
run 24 individual specimens you could
run three on a run you could run 12 on a
run but you can run up to 24 of course
you have to do quality control in any
molecular process there is an external
positive and negative control that must
be done with this assay of course you
can do daily QC if you wish or you can
do an IQ CP type plan and have a
designated frequency established for
doing your QC
this is a nice multicenter evaluation
that was done by dr. Harrington in the
group on the BB max enteric bacterial
panel it's a very nice paper showing
their evaluation of this panel they
compared the panel to the routine
culture into an enzyme immunoassay for
shigga toxin and showed very good
comparative results in this publication
it's a very large multicenter evaluation
with thousands of specimens and I think
if you want to read more about how they
went about doing their testing and their
findings this is a very good reference
for you to go to I might just address
some of the overall performance data in
these charts just to let you see how
robust this assay really is you can see
the top is the overall perspective the
bottom part is the overall retrospective
performance data this chart has both
unpreserved and Kerry Blair specimens
and you can see for both types of
specimens there is a very good agreement
and in the paper that was written by I
showed previous slide there was not that
much difference between unpreserved and
Kerry Blair specimen testing so that's
really up to your laboratory to decide
which one in which way you want to go or
use both in your testing and you can see
this is a very robust assay for
detecting these pathogens
next I'm going to talk about the
extended enteric bacterial panel this is
the text for organisms that you can see
listed on the left hand side is your
seniya eTech please ium onus and Vibrio
species now this extended enteric
bacterial panel is up to you to decide
how you would like to use you could
routinely use this on every specimen if
you so wish and you think that falls
within your select guideline for testing
your patients or perhaps you could be a
little bit more flexible in your usage
this is the way we went in our
laboratory we did not think that we
needed to test these pathogens on all of
our stool and we educated our clinicians
and have given them the opportunity to
add this on to their order but we do not
routinely do it on every specimen we
think that this testing on these unique
pathogens should somewhat be based on
the patient status the history and
clinical presentation rather than just
testing every stool specimen but of
course this will vary with each
institution and you need to make the
decision if this should be an extra
add-on or if you want to do it routinely
on all stools this is a very nice
multi-site evaluation of this assay for
your perusal to see how this aspect
performs you'll see that it's a very
robust assay in a very good assay for
the detection of these unusual stool
pathogens there is one thing I want to
make sure that you are aware of you do
not individually test the extended
bacterial panel you actually have to
test it along with the enteric bacterial
panel it is a snap-on add-on to that
panel and you do it together so it's one
sample one setup for the eight bacterial
pathogens
this is also some more information
showing you what a robust assay this is
as well this is from the beady max
extended enteric bacterial panel package
insert showing you for the unpreserved
and Carrie Blair specimens both of them
give you very good sensitivity and
specificity of the assay so it's up to
you which specimen type that you want to
test and as I said this makes a very
good add-on test for pathogens that
we've always had somewhat trouble in our
laboratory to detect and you need
specialized methods and some specialized
skill to look for so I think this is a
very very nice addition for those unique
patients that need to look for these
pathogens this is really a very nice way
to look for them so let's go through
over some questions that you might have
about this assay how are we using the BD
max
extended enteric bacterial pattern
pattern well we use it as a flexible
option for a more complete panel as I
said for those patients requiring such
testing now in our laboratory we haven't
seen these pathogens very often that are
in this extended panel so we didn't see
a need in our algorithm to have it
tested on every specimen but as I say
this is a decision that every laboratory
needs to make so I will just reiterate
at the bottom of this slide I said that
you do really need to develop an
algorithm and you need to educate
physicians to order both panels when
needed and you add on requests are
problematic so you can't individually
add on an extended bacterial panel so as
difficult as it can be we do need to
provide education in our algorithms to
our clinicians and so that they're sure
that they order the proper things
do we perform susceptibility testing on
Salmonella and Shigella well we might be
a bit of outliers but yes we do and it
was not a decision made by the
laboratory alone well we perform
susceptibility testing on both
Salmonella and Shigella species because
this was a request that was made by our
infectious disease physicians this is
something that you need to discuss with
your clinicians do they need to cept
ability testing they may need both they
may need neither or perhaps they only
want Shigella tested but this is
something that you need to discuss with
your own physicians in your own
institution next question are you always
able to subculture organisms
well we subculture all our positive
Salmonella and Shigella
from the submitted Carey Blair vial on
to McConkey AG and selenite broth if
needed and no we're not able to succumb
tur 100% but we do subculture most if
not all the Salmonella we're currently
averaging around 97% and somewhat less
of the Shigella sometimes also your sub
cultures will have low numbers of
colonies so you need to really be on
guard to look for low numbers of
colonies from your kerry Blair do we
send an aliquot of kerry blair medium or
an isolated organism to the Public
Health Department well this brings up a
very important point if you're switching
from your standard manual type
microbiology for stool cultures to use
molecular testing you really do need to
let your Public Health Department know
because they might start seeing some
different submissions from your
laboratory so you need to talk to them
about what their expectations are for
your sending of organisms to them our
Public Health Department in Los Angeles
instructed us to send Salmonella and
Shigella eye slits on auger slants when
possible if we are not able to culture a
positive molecular test
we are then sending a Kerry Blair medium
aliquot to them for shigga toxin
positive specimens we were instructed to
send a Kerry Blair medium aliquot that
was frozen as I said this is what our
Health Department told us to do but
yours might have different suggestions
for how you should handle this situation
do stool specimens present problems for
molecular testing after all it's poo is
messy specimen is it going to cause a
lot of problems with amplification we've
had very very little problems with
amplification we've had very few
so-called unresolved results they do
occur on occasion well less than 1% well
less there are various compounds in
stools that could lead to this
suppression of amplification that leads
to an unresolved result and not produce
a result the most common interfering
substance with most assays are lubricant
and solutions that are used for specimen
collections and but we're kind of
blindsided in the laboratory we have no
clue what might really be used for
collection or at be in these specimens
so we deal with an unresolved issue but
as I say there's very low percentage and
should not present you a problem
have you had questions with physicians
well yes
there has been some confusion between
Shigella species and shigga toxin and
some general confusion with the presence
of a sugar toxin what does a sugar toxin
me so we have had to educate some even
at the point of phone calls at the time
of presenting the result to a clinician
but I think that's one of the roles that
a microbiology has is continued
education and I have to admit that not
everyone as as informed about molecular
testing as others so yes sometimes we do
have to explain the result we also have
sometimes just have to explain that
molecular testing cannot be used for a
test of cure so what have I learned from
these physician communications well
overall I've learned that patient
reports need to be very clear and
informative we've included an
explanation paragraph with our molecular
results explaining what the results mean
one could laugh and say I'm not sure
that anyone ever reads those but let's
hope that some people might and we do
feel that it's certainly necessary to
provide some education about these newer
methods because I do think that a lot of
clinicians are not necessarily informed
we before starting all of these assays
of course we had educate educational
fliers I actually went to discussion
groups different meetings with our
infectious disease and Gi people to
discuss this testing talked to them at
answered their questions and even though
this was beneficial and they thanked me
for coming and I'm sure you will go
through the same process I doubt if it
will eliminate all your calls but it
certainly did help but I do have
happiness to present to you that even
though you'll get some calls to start
with over time the calls really go down
in numbers instead of getting calls to
help
them understand the test you're going to
start getting called thanking you for a
rapid result it was very helpful in the
diagnosis and I think it's the final
comment I just have to say that for some
reason I know the reason we can't know
everything a clinician knows and a
clinician can't know everything that the
laboratory does
and so basically molecular testing and
results are really not understood by all
clinicians so whenever you're starting
anything like this you're one of your
primary roles is going to be education
so let's move on to the BD max enteric
viral panel yes they're a beating Max
pale for detection of virus pathogens I
can say happily yes one was newly
cleared in December of 2018 it's a five
target panel that detects norovirus of
course the most common viral pathogen
causing infectious diarrhea and four
additional pathogens of viral
gastroenteritis and some of those have
varying degree of prevalence certainly
in your population I'm very happy to
have such a panel because we've been
having to send these to reference
laboratories for testing so now we will
be able to bring this testing into our
own laboratory the testing can be
performed on unpreserved soft to
diarrhea stool or it can also be
performed on carry clear transport media
the stool preparation and testing is
much like all of the other assays that
are performed on the BD max you use
either the Carrie Blair or unpreserved
stool specimen with an inoculation loop
you will inoculate the sample buffer
tube and it will be vortexed and then
loaded on to the beading backs I've not
had the pleasure of doing this assay yet
we're currently getting prepared to
start testing and doing our verification
and runs and such for the viral panel
and we're very much looking forward to
being able to also offer this in our
laboratory how does this test reform
overall it has very very high test
performance in both of the unpreserved
and Carrie Blair specimens so is a
robust assay and provide much help in
the diagnosis of these types of
pathogens
next is the BD max enteric parasite
panel
what can I say about parasite laboratory
detection that we aren't all just
thinking about it's of course the manual
concentration for parasites is a very
labor-intensive process it has variable
sensitivity it can be quite tedious and
I think you do have to be very high
skilled to recognize all the pathogens
in the milieu of a stool and overall
what is the sensitivity because we are
looking at a very small amount of stool
in a concentrated slide so that makes
you really do wonder what the
sensitivity of this these manual crepes
might be there's also multiple methods
that are required to examine a stool if
you're looking for the parasites that
are necessary and some of these methods
might have variable sensitivity and
specificity when we're looking at a
slide we're unable to tell the
difference between entamoeba histolytica
and disbar also it costs quite a bit of
money for each case detected in both
labor and multiple test methods also is
over there on the left hand side I've
said a lot of people want to order
multiple specimens the standard has
always been three specimens collections
for patients and so that adds to the
volume in your laboratory and the cost
because you're doing so many specimens
per patient and I don't know about your
population but in my population we have
a very low percentage of parasites so
it's really been a very big frustration
for people in my laboratory although
they greatly appreciate the science of
parasitology and they think that it's an
amazing science with all of the
organisms and and everything that goes
with the detection of parasites but they
do so much work and they get so few
positives but they don't really get very
very much reward in what they're doing
that's always been an issue in
laboratory so I have to say that the one
celebration that we had out in our
laboratory was when we switched over
from manual parasitology to doing
molecular testing because it was just
really greatly appreciated by our
technologists in our laboratory this
panel is designed to detect the common
highly pathogenic parasite Giardia
Cryptosporidium and entamoeba
histolytica and it does specifically
detect histolytica does not have the
confusion with this bar you can of
course use it for testing of parasites
alone it is an individual panel or you
can use it in conjunction with the other
panels the enteric bacterial and
extended bacterial and viral panel that
i've already talked about it does
require one additional step in
processing over the other panels that
i've discussed there is a preheating
step for approximately 30 minutes to
ensure that you're adequately extracting
the DNA from the protozoans you can use
unpreserved stools for parasite exam and
also formalin-fixed this has been very
helpful being able to use unpreserved
stools even in the past when we had
adequate collection devices given to all
of our clinicians for overand parasite
exams it never failed that on weekly
occasions several times per week
sometimes we would receive a fresh duel
for over in parasite exam manual exam
and we had to reject it due to its long
transport time so this gives us a
capability of not rejecting those
unpreserved stools it can also eliminate
the need for the less sensitive and
complex methodologies such as all the
EIA s that we used to do for
Cryptosporidium and Giardia to
supplement our manual testing which
might have been insensitive we also have
less need for fluorescent microscopy so
you would not have to have those methods
available in your lab
so I think this has really greatly
helped us in our lab this is a study
that we did because we were so into the
parasite panel we decided to produce
some of the good findings that we found
we particularly liked having as you can
see in the upper left hand grid less
exposure to stool less exposure to the
10% formalin and all of these stains and
alcohols that are evolved in the
processing of parasitology we also of
course it eliminates scope reading so
you only have about 10 processing steps
when you do a b d max enteric pathogen
panel versus over-30 when you're doing a
manual parasite exam and hands-on time
is over to the right hand side you can
see the hand on time per minutes per
specimen you have only about 2.7 minutes
for a b d max panel versus 19 minutes
per specimen for a manual parasitology
exam so there's 85 percent decrease in
hands-on time once you move to molecular
parasitology the performance is quite
good in both unpreserved in formal and
preserved specimens so I don't think
that you'll have to worry about the risk
of falling off in sensitivity from
moving to an enteric parasite panel
so the question comes about is this
enough do AMD's ask for additional
testing well no they don't but for some
populations additional testing might be
required such as outlined in your IDSA
guidelines if there's any outbreaks or
unusual parasites moving around your
community such as Cyclospora HIV we
might need to do more routing microspore
idiot detection and if you have a lot of
exotic travel you may have to look for
other parasites we did maintain our
manual O&P method in our laboratory for
such requests but and also for unusual
circumstances and sometimes you just
have that demanding position that just
wants everything done but we've had a
steady decrease in orders for manual O&P
over time and now we only schedule our
parasite lab up in about four hours a
week two hours two times a week and
sometimes we don't even need to have it
open because we don't have any specimens
to process it has been a great labor
savings for us another question do we
test the BD max parasite panel times
three like we did our manual open
parasite exams no we are not doing it
times three
we feel that due to the increased
sensitivity that we only need to do one
we have ordering restrictions
established and we consistently follow
them so we do not have multiple orders
coming in for parasitology to our
molecular laboratory
how will reimbursement policies affect
enteric pathogen testing well in our
inpatient testing and the laboratory
costs are perhaps more important than
reimbursement amounts for this sector
due to the single fee payments to
hospitals but outpatient testing I think
we have to be on alert there's a lot of
people with poor insurance plans that
have evolved that place increasing
payment burden on the patient so we need
to make sure that we're performing tests
a value that actively play a role in the
patient management so in the future we
also we may need justification provided
for reimbursement for such testing so
that directs one toward targeted tests
election and testing and also as I said
it really targets or our need to develop
algorithms for this select testing so we
can direct it with positions or maybe
not as good about choosing which tests
should be run and finally let's talk
about the c-diff panel that is near and
dear to my heart we've done a lot of
work on c difficile at Cedars and so I
feel somewhat comfortable talking about
how do we test for c difficile well I
think my first comment would be it's
quite compliment complicated we've
evolved from using nucleic acid testing
alone into a two-step algorithm which
uses nucleic acid testing plus toxin a
and B detection using enzyme immunoassay
now we might have a unique situation at
Cedars but we do a lot of work
investigative work in infection control
with C difficile and we have a very very
strong stewardship program and so we
wanted to make sure that we could
separate our patients that are colonized
from our infected patients that required
therapy and also we wanted to make sure
that we were properly reporting the
correct patients to regulatory agencies
so we felt that using a two-step
algorithm with molecular testing plus an
enzyme immunoassay was the best way for
us to achieve this so our two-step
algorithm at Cedars includes
its first performing a b d maxi diff
panel which of course targets the toxin
b g now of course i'm sure you're quite
aware that the toxins b gene is a very
good way to detect c difficile in a
stool specimen but you do not know at
that time if it has active toxin so the
way we resolved that to know if there is
a large amount of active toxin present
is to perform a toxin a B enzyme
you know a say that is capable of
detecting this active toxin our
algorithm we've been using it for over
of almost three years now but it's been
given validation by the publication of
the IDSA clinical practice guidelines in
2018 this says this is one reasonable
way to go about doing this testing and
these are the guidelines that can
provide you some very very excellent
information about the proper performance
of C difficile testing using molecular
assays so the important issues that are
in these guidelines is the physician
nurse education to improve patient
selection and stool collection is a very
important point we need to make sure
that we're only accepting stools which
are truly diarrhea so we're starting
around with one of the first comments
that I made in this presentation was we
need to know what diarrhea is and so we
want to only test c difficile on cases
of unexplained diarrhea that are greater
than or 3 loose stools for 24 hours
we've had an initial issue with laxative
administration at Cedars and so now we
have a very ongoing protocol to try to
make sure that stool specimens for
c-diff testing does not have someone
that has taken laxatives of course they
still have the guidelines in the in the
for age testing and now it's down to
greater than or equal to one year of age
should can be tested but at that age of
course you have a very high prevalence
of asymptomatic carriage and you have to
test with care children 1 to 2 years of
age you test cautiously older children
you can test when other causes have been
eliminated
our laboratory policies we have
rejections for repeat testing of
specimens within 7 days and less new
episode of diarrhea and we do school
dual viscosity checks even though we
have it written everywhere that it must
be a diarrhea stool we do a final check
in the laboratory to make sure
we are truly testing diarrheal soft
stools and we prohibit the testing of
forum stools the best practice c-diff
guidelines also say that we've chosen to
go with the two-step algorithm but if
you have perfect stool collection and
all those things that I just discussed
are in perfect form you can do just
nucleic acid testing or molecular
testing alone we do not think that we
have the perfect stool collection in our
laboratory so we that's why we move to
the two-step algorithm that detects a
seed F and presence of active toxin so
we have used the two-step with the BT
max panel as our primary and the EIA as
our secondary but of course the seed if
guidelines also say that you could use
glutamate dehydrogenase as your primary
test if you so wish we had feel that the
molecular testing with the PD max panel
has helped us better differentiate our
truely colonized patients and that's why
we felt it was very important to
maintain molecular testing as our
primary test in our algorithm and this
is our diagnostic algorithm for the
detection as I had said we primarily use
the c diff panel as our primary test and
if it is detected as shown on the right
hand side we will reflux
to the EIA if it's PCR positive and E is
Eve we say that the patient is infected
and the patient certainly requires
treatment if the PCR is positive and the
enzyme assay is negative on the
left-hand side of this branch chart we
say this patient is most likely
colonized and the physician has the
information with the discretion to treat
if they so feel necessary but we feel
that this patient is most likely
colonized
so in summary I presented that there's a
variety of pathogens that cause GI
infections and they require an
assortment of labor demanding manual
detection methods to identify the
causative organism classic methods vary
and specificity and sensitivity and are
often randomly ordered due to a lack of
physician understanding of these test
methods in comparison if you decide to
use a select multiplex molecular panel
it can enable your laboratory to test
for the most common GI pathogens while
providing improved specificity and
sensitivity but of course physician
education is necessary and you need to
assist with proper test ordering and
it's the time to start producing good
algorithms for such purposes used
properly molecular panels are tests of
value they can supply cost-effective
diagnostic tests for the significant GI
pathogens that could have been
undiagnosed using classic methods and
those are my final words so I thank you
for your attention and now I'm ready to
answer any of your questions or comments
that you might have thank you for
listening
you
Thank You dr. Morgan for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live qan of the webinars if
you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for now okay
dr. Marie must get started your first
question is what percentage of your
stool orders are for all four panels
versus single panels um that's a very
interesting question I have to say that
most of our orders are not for all for
most our most common
order is for the enteric bacterial
pathogen panel and I would say the next
most popular would be the parasitology
we get very few requests currently for
the extended panel our clinicians were
fully educated on such panel I just
think that perhaps in our patient
population using the guidelines and
things that we educated on they have not
thought it to be all that necessary so I
would say we do about a twenty a day of
the enteric bacterial pathogen about ten
of the parasite and possibly one or two
of the extended we are just getting
going on the viral panel so I don't have
any information to give you on that
dr. Morgan was it hard to get physicians
on board with a panel approach to
diagnose and Heric pathogens well you
know it ended up not being quite as as
difficult as we thought it was going to
be I did have my stewardship and ID team
help me go to the hospital clinicians to
help with education we sent out from
some very simple flyers providing
education to our outreach clinicians and
we talked to our emergency department
doctors and they they seem to like the
concept of the organization of the
panels and we didn't really have much
issue getting that started on occasion
we do get callbacks to add on a panel
and I think that's understandable if
something came up with the case that
maybe they didn't expect but we were
very fortunate we did not have a lot of
problems
dr. Morgan how does your lab facilitate
the isolation of Public Health organisms
such as salmonella before sending to
your state or local Public Health lab
well first off you need to speak to your
local Public Health lab we were one of
the first people in our community to
start using molecular testing so we
really had to have some heart-to-heart
and really sit down and talk a lot about
it because they we didn't quite know how
to do all of this but now it's becoming
more common and you'll probably get a
fairly canned response I would think
from your public health department on
what you should do we do most of our
testing from Kerry Blair medium so we do
as soon as we know that we have a
positive Salmonella or Shigella on our
testing panel we will do a subculture
from the Kerry Blair I as I mentioned in
my talk on occasion we do not recover an
isolate if we do not recover an isolate
we will then send them an aliquot of the
Kerry Blair but that was with the
understanding of our Public Health
Department
Thank You dr. Morgan now we decide which
impaired panel to test all patients well
we do not decide of course in the
laboratory that's decided upon by the
clinician we did in our education as I
was talking before suggested they look
at the guidelines for which panel should
be used I am available if there is some
question by the clinician about which
panel for travel or whatever
circumstance they might want to order
but that's pretty much a clinician
decision and not based in the laboratory
dr. Morgan how would you recommend a
small lab that sends out their own PS to
incorporate the parasitic panel with
send out of Ont um I think that I
understand this question in that it
would prevent you from having to do a
send out of course the panel covers the
three most common parasites you might
still have to send out a few things if
the clinicians want to investigate other
parasitic possibilities but I think it's
a wonderful option for bringing in your
parasitology screening into your
laboratory and preventing send out tests
I think that would be a wonderful
application of that enteric parasite
panel I would like to take our audience
for so many great questions we have so
many coming in we have time for just a
couple more but I do want to remind our
audience that any questions we did not
have time for today and those that are
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by dr. Morgan via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration so dr. Morgan let's
sit and just a couple more what is the
physician insists on running c-diff on
hard stool samples oh what a painful in
question and you know this early on when
we've implemented doing molecular
testing which is now about three years
ago or so I've lost track it just seems
like a blur we had more issues with the
rejection of stools and more calls from
physicians I remember one famous one
early on when I actually sent a video of
the stool as I shook it in the container
to show the clinician how hard the stool
really was it sometimes clinicians don't
see the patient's stool the patient
tells them they have diarrhea or the
nurse might say they have diarrhea but
by the time they collect a stool the
stool solid again so it's not just
sometimes as I said the clinician is
unaware that the stool is corrected to
solid so if the techs get into
issues with physicians and have trouble
expressing their opinion about the stool
I'll take it over and talk to them and
assure them that we were correct in that
the stool is actually hard and that this
is not appropriate testing per our
testing algorithm that's what we do
Thank You dr. Morgan and we'll wrap with
this final question how are you
maintaining expertise for your cat
parasitic challenges with your
diminished microscopic time in training
that's an excellent question and near
and dear to my heart since our cap
inspection is next week
and we're very concerned with training
and competency of course all the time we
never saw a lot of parasites to begin
with I'm based in you know the middle of
Los Angeles with a very immune
suppressed non-traveling population
really we don't have a traveling clinic
or anywhere where we see unusual
parasites so we didn't get a lot of
experience looking at parasites from
doing a patient specimens we do still
maintain our parasitology lab and still
have ongoing processing so the texts do
still have ongoing competency and daily
at least twice a week
concentration of a few samples so they
do not lose that ability we of course do
competency every year we have cap
specimens coming to our laboratory but
we that's the way we keep it up but our
prevalence of parasites was so terribly
low I do not believe that they received
a lot of long going competency from our
patient specimens so we try to do it for
pictures cap specimens and things like
that to keep up their competency I think
that might end up yeah sorry about that
yes I does um conclude our Q&A dr.
Morgan thank you for your time today and
your important involvement in optimizing
GI testing do you have any final
comments for our audience no I just
think that um I guess my final comment
would be
we have really found a great ability to
become more efficient and we think
provide very rapid and good results to
our clinicians using molecular testing
it always has to be done in the best of
circumstances with the best of sterility
techniques and I think if you really
work to do a good package you're really
supplying very good information for the
patient and at the same time making your
laboratory far more efficient and with
that I'll close
thank you again dr. Morgan we'd also
like to thank fabrics and our sponsor BV
for underwriting today's educational
webcast one more time I'd like to thank
the audience for joining us today and
for their interesting questions again we
did have a lot of questions that we did
not have time to answer and dr. Morgan
will answer those following the
presentation via email
now this webcast can be viewed on-demand
through August 2019 lab routes will
alert you via email when it's available
for replay we encourage you to share
that email with your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event a quick
poll will now pop up on your screen your
answers and suggestions will help
improve our webinar program and are
greatly appreciated thanks for joining
us until next time goodbye